I made up a new adjective The look
of the person wearing Apple's new headset is
scary
But it's a
delicious crunchy or moth moss It's
pretty difficult, but it's
fun It's really
long, but it's
still interesting Luffy Luffy scene
Mappa Mapathy that gives amazing results even in difficult times How
old people drive and how dangerous young men
drive 5 ways Dangerous feelings when playing FF7 Reverse Fantasy
is sorry I don't know what role it plays  Situation my
number is ridiculous The
face of a person who says he's definitely undergoing
plastic surgery The heart of a person who doesn't mind doing something that goes against his morals for the sake of likes and views The
pain a man feels when his crotch is cut
Nibunibushi The one who takes all sorts of things in the direction of politics
Left and right extreme beautiful
CGI bash nize C One more finger Attachment
to a non-existent woman AI and a
scarce way of speaking younger than poor Money makes people
laugh with their noses  It's funny, my heart is pounding